Here is my solution for anagrams().
I chose to write a helper function called find_anagrams().
That takes the letters in the phrase with all the spaces removed.
I'm calling find_anagrams() with the spaces replaces by nothing,
so we get rid of the spaces in the original phrase,
and then I want to make sure that the anagrams I find--the words are in alphabetical order.
The way I'm going to do that is by passing into find_anagrams() the previous word
on every recursive call.
For the first call, we can just say the previous word was the empty string.
Then I find I have to also pass in the shortest allowable word we're looking for.
So what does find_anagrams() do?
It's got the same kind of structure that we say before.
We initialize an empty set. At the end we're going to return it.
Then we use the previously defined find_words function.
Remember for Scrabble, we take any letters in our hand and find all the possible words.
Let's do that. For the words that come back, are they long enough?
Are they greater than what were allowed for shortest,
and are they in alphabetical order? Are they greater than the previous word?
If so, then use the previously defined removed function to tell me what
the remaining letters are.
If there is no remainder, then let's just add that word into the results and we're done.
Otherwise, let's recursively call find_anagrams() with the remainder
and then add in that result with a space in between them.
This is how we're finding anagrams that are longer than just one word long.